this video is brought to you by better
help as two people who have been in
therapy for many years now we are proud
to be partnered with these
[Music]
guys citizens of the reject Nation I
have a very important message for
everyone before we watch the finale of
hasbin Hotel Roxy claims to read every
single one of the comments on these
videos let's put this to the test I want
to really see if she's the real deal ask
her some questions in the comments let's
see if she responds I hope you respond
to every single one of them I respond to
nice people who want to talk to me and I
do read every single comment let's see
guys we're here for the finale very very
excited we had some predictions that we
laid down in the uh episode 7 let's see
if any of them come true hey yo leave a
like that would be very much appreciated
thanks preer for helping us edit down
these highlights thank you to all who
have follow us at our patreon page
becoming super sexy rejects over there
you get the full length retion watch
sink up with your own copy of hasman
Hotel John and Greg I am Greg do sever
shows exclusively over there with Hots
and watch songs included and now let's
ver Journey ver Journey let's can't wait
to V Journey with you guys to the depths
of
[Music]
hell I can't believe this is
finale the dream who is this oh is this
TV boy no way they're going to [__]
right oh my God I love this guy looks
like your little hotel didn't work out
so well oh aliser I cannot wait to watch
you get oh this is written by Adam Stein
different so Vivan didn't write this one
I wish my mom was here to see this me
too I know begging for that Lilith
DPC ready for victorious combat what in
the hell are you supposed to be General
penious reporting for Duty I'll turn
those wrapped scallions into soul
solders in no time at all really he has
grown on me so much I love him base
seats fortifications reinforce the
Southern Wall create a moot around the
perimeter to stop a ground assault okay
the dead rats if you see an angel stab
it no nope nope hey hey heyy not him oh
that's angel
dust Sinners we got 24 hours before the
extermination begins let's get to work
Stephie beatric I still feel like is an
underrated Talent honestly I wonder how
she feels internally about killing her
own kind Stephanie beatress no
vagy I wasn't responding to what you
said I was watching the show but you're
right even people who aren't staying
here yet Cherry look I can't resist to
fight okay especially when I get to tag
team with this oh my God they're all
coming together yes and we are we are
going to win but in case we don't no I
want you all to know that getting to
know you has been the biggest honor of
my life that's sweet but don't put doubt
in there I know you all tried I have
seen the good in all of you you mean
these like five
people live tonight however you want
because that's
die all right let's give it up for not
dying love not
dying
drinks oh the celebratory night before a
courageous Last Stand a surprising
thrill to witness these Wayward Souls
find
connection I really like them Alister
they let me put on roach puppet shows
without booing ah an enjoyable
Collective to be around uhhuh I dub thee
King roach oh to understand your Twisted
little mind that's
disgusting oh
no okay I'm like waiting for it yeah and
you're not off snorting a l off some
hunks ABS one cannibal po boy them yeah
I know what you mean man Charlie said
live tonight however we wanted make out
so pour me a fresh one and let's get to
living you don't want to be inebriated
when you're going to battle Cherry tell
her I want to tell you that I tell her I
love I'd love to wish you good luck in
the battle serenes you are have always
been a worthy opponent with the most
brilliant explosive this is like the
Ross and Rachel of the show well they
won't they anyway I guess please don't
die tomorrow okay
bye don't be gross don't be gross you
know I hear he's
got well how do you want me to respond
to that Craig
yes I'll take one of
them what if we
lose you
yes true Oh
yay
facts heavy tell
her that's
enough
marry me yeah
[Music]
what I mean they're doing the more than
anything sign but what have they not
said to each
other they love each other more than
anything a oh I got happy nipple
chills I didn't know nipple chills came
in the happy
variety no well they usually come in
excited
Goose Adam is demon like just the most
ridiculous character Slaughter every in
that [__] hotel and you all remember V
it's
vagy mouth out her ass you just chill
loot I want Adam to get his ass handed
to him so bad is he gonna live through
this
season
no come on let's go go let's go oh this
is good be good now for your
souls Angel dust's boss was there with
the TV guy Valentino yeah let the
slaughter
begin get in there
[Music]
Alistair they appear to have some kind
of Shield sir oh really I didn't see
this giant shield in front of me you
dumb [__] no
[__] yes all Angelic weapons fire at
will hey yelling while fighting doesn't
help uh I mean you need to talk over it
sounds Al Shield is working uhoh don't
say something's working
otherwise damn baggy looks good
this Adam has power yeah well he was the
[Music]
first
oh this the first time they' be coming
face to face Adam first man next to die
who the [__] are you Alis pleasure to be
meeting you quite a pleasure I'm about
to end youring
life I can't help but I love Alistar I'm
going to be devastated if he's
evil you really think you can take me on
a mortal soul is no match for me EDG
Lord this a cool
fight you think you're tough [__] huh
tougher than
you and worst you're
sloppy get
him you you red piece of you much red
shut up too much red I'm going to wipe
that [__] eating grin off your face cuz
radio is dead what just
happened no
oh you
Alis this is than sex I did not expect
that disagree with you there radio's not
dead but it is ending this
broadcast ooh that was interesting
Adam's stronger get ready for yeah You'
have to assume he was strong name but
got it
vagatha it's like
Agatha she's a apologizing she probably
has the most power if she doesn't
realize
it oh my God
gramble you all right squirt get
somewhere
safe
[Music]
my damn this is wild this is a
full-blown
fight we aren't going to last long
unless we do something about him oh no
of course serenus no he's the only one
that I think might die fight in mind yes
yay he's got two dingling I love you he
said it remember me that was kind of
hard I hope he doesn't die kind of love
him now and charge the death ray yes
sires crazy mother I love how this is
coming full circle yeah everything's
like tying back to the first couple
[Music]
episodes oh jeez you did good buddy
Charlie I'm so sorry no there's going to
be more to
[Music]
it yeah least go there it
is let's run yep House of the Dragons
there's that Darkness look who thinks
they're badass she is the traitor came
to
die no oh
God
before I take your life I'm going to
tear that other eye out of your face was
like
Kook jeez this is really good action
it's like an anime faggies surprise
[__] unleash who you really are risking
your Immortal Life for Sinners these
Sinners are my family these Sinners are
by my family he is the worst you should
have stayed in your place
girly yes that's princess of hell to you
pig the [__] that
hurts can make him bleed oh tail you
always were
weak no
[Music]
no
yes
do it then correct your mistake
seriously you're pathetic you know that
carai live knowing that you only do
because I let you oh I would love to say
that to someone I think of at least
three people yeah but is she stuck under
there or oh god oh no this fight was
cute and all but it's time to die with
the rest of them
Charlie
yes okay seriously how many of you
freaks do I have to fight oh wa there's
a whole face under there see you messed
with my daughter and now I am going to
[__] you well this just got interesting
[__] you up Dad wait what did I
say now I'm going
to you're the most hated being in all of
creation well your first wife didn't
seem to hate what I had to off the
second nice stke douchebag Hold Still
You
slippery but where is
aliser no oh God Hotel I got you Dad
look
out
yeah
a you come at me and
my you're in my house [__] that was a
cool shot his house as hell who who dad
he's had
enough no murder I'm theing man and
you're just someing clown or something I
started everything on Earth all of
mankind came from these fing
nuts these nuts disgusting fuing
losers
whoa oh my God oh my God
[Music]
not I like that that was an amazing
reveal that's amazing take your little
friends and go home I think he makes it
Retreat all exorcists fall back oh my
God it's going to be full-blown War next
season God's going going to get involved
so who's up for pancakes I haven't had
pancakes in years I had pancakes this
week oh you looked great for having
pancakes the janitor saide Charlie told
me to stab so I did congrats to Charlie
and her crew for not being totally
useless for once a where's Alister well
there's still something big is going to
happen I
think he did it for us a final song the
ultimate
but but he's alive we don't
[Music]
know do what you
could did better than
usual why the frown you're the first one
to change this time yes
you can do this now I know it for your
story is just begun Seas toe you've
changed my mind you've touched their
hearts found the good and souls gone bad
she's a great woman the crowd is gone
but by God Charlie the show it must go
on must go
on greater
[Music]
tell would this motivation for
Redemption be the same
in look at them they're all doing it
together of's ruins news across
withcer a they're all positive Al
missing fled with his tail between his
legs what the future of Hell belongs to
the
no this place of there's a chill the and
bar escaped being killed by a hair it's
going to come back stronger sorry to
disappoint that is not where this ends
no I'm hungry for free
like never before the constraints of my
deal surely have a back door what is the
deal I don't
know he wants to get out of
hell oh he wants to be the ruler yeah
but uncp your wings from who got to be
Lilith right gotta
[Applause]
be Al's
[Music]
back
good day in
[Music]
hello
no
what
Redemption that's crazy Adam is dead
your deal is done and I'm in charge now
is it who I think it is your Brad is
threatening the very Foundation of
heaven and if you want to stay here yeah
you're brat you're going down there and
stop that bding in heaven you understand
me
Lilith yeah it's exact almost exactly
how we thought they would tease Lilith
where he talk you kept saying this whole
season they didn't cast her yet so You'
see a little bit of her but then they
would it would be the final moment so
she's hiding out on the beach wow and
Adam is dead dead she's worse than
everyone else she mad in her
daughter that's cruel
selfish she enjoying
life damn for once Prime video
recommends something that kind of makes
sense a little Nicki lines up yeah that
actually lines up a lot that does make
sense yeah wow and you and I love him I
know Sandman I also love today's sponsor
thank you to better help for sponsoring
this video I've literally just finished
a therapy session and I wanted to shoot
this cuz I'm in this state of knowing
why I Champion mental health supports so
much in the past few weeks work's been a
little bit hectic it's led me to miss
some sessions and I really don't like
doing that and sometimes that's when the
weight really starts to pile on a lot of
restless nights a lot of fatigue a lot
of I can't sleep even though I'm so
tired sometimes just a very deep-seated
sense of Gloom meditating and sometimes
journaling are my daily go-to but
sometimes they just don't cut it when
I'm trying to pinpoint why I'm down and
really especially after a session like
today therapy just really helps clear
the fog discussing the feelings is a
critical step for me especially as
someone who's diagnosed with ADHD type 2
bipolar and PTSD it's truly a
Cornerstone to my well-being and I'm not
alone in this many of us here at real
rejects are in therapy facing our own
challenges from depression to anxiety or
just needing a non-judgmental space to
voice our thoughts this year I've been
working on most days of the week to keep
my physical health strong and I really
do Champion therapy as a way to
strengthen my mental resilience and for
many better help is integral to that
process There's real value in better
help's accessible and adaptable service
they match you with the licensed
therapist and provide the option to
switch if necessary ensuring the right
fit for your mental health Journey as
this year winds down and we confront
life's complexities do consider
betterhelp as a resource really happy to
be partnered with them this month so you
can go to betterhelp.com sreal rejects
for 10% off your first month again
that's b t r h lp.com slre rejects so
join us in moving forward stronger
together thank you again and I also love
that Roxy be wearing rejected material
around here oh yeah baby a sooka a soda
yeah I think this one of our most
underrated shirts but not our space PS
of the Galaxy I spread my legs for for
some reason now stay I'm rubbing off
on I want this one uh do you want this
one I just love how that's what everyone
does when they come here give me that
give me a shirt no we're talking about
the shirts I'm say I want this one it's
really cool yeah sure I didn't say give
me oh my God Greg I got let me hype up
your shirts like it's so cool I want
this one do you want this one that's
what I said well I got I've got three
more in development right now going to
be what are they I don't want to ruin it
I want to ruin it are any of them Purge
related yeah that is just like a boom in
thing here everyone knows Purge my Purge
pillows on the ground I'm sorry to hear
that uh all right well we've made it to
the finale of hasman hotel if you're
listening to this on Apple or
Spotify uh we watched episodes seven and
eight back to back a lot of our things
that we I mean the main thing with
Lilith I I guess I wasn't expecting her
to be in heaven uh which is kind of
surprising but nothing really surp it's
weird like surprising things don't even
surprise me because the show can kind of
just it has car blanch to sort of do
whatever the hell they want are we sure
that was Heaven she go the angel goes up
and says if you want to stay here where
the hell else would it be oh she could
be on Earth yeah oh it was a beach yeah
it was a beach right oh damn too people
probably commented and then the ad
played and then they're like no Greg
it's not heaven a damn I don't know it
could be Heaven no you're probably right
I don't know that right I'm just saying
we we know she's not in Hell clearly and
we know she wants to stay there she
Paradise you know she's having a
parist par
paral is there like a verb for par for
experience in Paradise par
paral she's getting the dickle and perah
yeah that sounds like something
else yeah I think that I'm not sure
where exactly she is but what we do know
is she's not in Hell taking care of her
daughter she's not showing up for her
daughter the way Lucifer is showing up
for the daughter
uh she clearly has some deal with the
angels that she is able to be where she
is for as long as hell stays tame you
know and but then now they're like you
can't stay here unless you go take care
of that [__] but who has the power over
it seems like she want has nothing to do
with any of that [__] in hell so why
would she be the one reigning over
Alistair I don't know that she is
reigning over aliser it's just been my
theory this whole time because they were
gone for the same amount of time no it
pokes a it does yeah it sounds like like
there was some there there's some other
Lynch pin some other conduit for all
this stuff you know yeah because and
then even Alistar song at the end like
clipped my wings mhm from who we need
answers but in terms of a finale it was
action-packed
action-packed yeah I mean they set up
this the season they were like we're
gonna heaven and hell are going to fight
and then the finale Heaven and Hell
fought and then there's chances of
redemption my question that was the
biggest
reveal of serenes yeah he went like this
was her plan the whole time and sent
just sacrifices himself for his friends
truly truly does the selfless thing and
he shows up in heaven and if you factor
in the pilot as a true episode one he
was the first villain right so the full
character Arc but he kisses Cherry Bomb
and he says I love you and then he goes
off and he does something very brave and
it doesn't
work but he does it why end up in heaven
but the plan why why I guess I guess my
question is no one wants this purge
thing to happen anymore right Purge
yep no no one wants it to happen
anymore and it's like poking to Teddy
Bears um bir it's different when you're
like face to face with the just like
right your eyes
bir bir uh yeah the no one wants this to
happen no one wants it to happen happen
this extermination and you know they
want us to get the hotel going again
which they have already done what would
be the greater purpose of
Rehabilitation when the goal before was
uh to eliminate The Purge from happening
and just hear you
saying eliminate eliminated from
happening I mean the idea was like okay
you prevent less people from from being
excised if if more people are able to go
to heaven because of the overpopulation
problem right would the goal still be to
get you to go to heaven because clearly
now that Charlie knows what heaven's
really like that it's not all it's made
out to be would they want to want to go
to heaven or or would it just be about
making hell a more you know a stronger
Community well in heaven you don't have
the risk of
extermination well I think the I think
in this finale what they were showing
was they don't even want that
extermination element to be happening in
hell so I they have a bigger goal in
their hands of of a war there has to be
some type of deal made with heaven where
they're not killing each other killing
anyone in hell um right because hell
serenus probably doesn't want to be
there and they don't probably want him
there yeah CU hell's just more of a
community it's not it's not in the same
way of how hell has been pitched to us
for so long of like souls go there and
then they're punished and they're
tortured they're they're just uh it's a
civilization essentially some of them
but we saw the v's you know you can be
punished uh but you can also just live
there you know maybe unless the v's are
in charge true you know like under under
Charlie it's good and and some of the
rulers and leaders but we don't even
know what alistar's plan would be if he
was able to be the
ruler yeah so I guess they would want
but they don't know about that so I'm
like why would Charlie want to I guess
what would be the motivation of hasman
Hotel of like the actual physical
property of hasman hotel to inspire
people to rehabilitate you know to Go to
Heaven Charlie doesn't know that
heaven's not a good place she went there
and she had questions but I don't think
she went there and was like screw this
place I think she thinks that still
there's some beauty there okay but we've
seen more true I'm shocked that they
killed Adam vaggie would know that's
pretty [__] up
there yeah vaggie would know but vaggie
didn't even tell her anything yet but
vaggie might we might see that Arc in
season too vaggie saying like do why do
we even want people to go to heaven like
of course we want them to be better but
mhm and apparently you go only go to
heaven if you die I think it's it beats
the AL this is what it is Greg it beats
the alternative of being gone for
eternity because it's not like you're
redeemed and you go to heaven you're he
died and went to heaven true as opposed
to if you die in hell and then you're
gone that's fair I mean but you can also
die if you're soul in heaven apparently
according to this like Angels were
killed and right I just think she wants
her people to be able to if they die go
to heaven as opposed to Nowhere yeah
there has to be some type of a not an
alliance but an understanding that forms
between Heaven and Hell and there's that
one girl that we think that we can have
an alliance with who is in heaven who
they did the duet with in episode
six you know what I'm talking about
Charlie the girl that Charlie did the
dght with the younger girl in heaven
yeah yeah yeah she's got our back
she wants the alliance yeah yeah I think
there's a there's a lot more crazy uh
World building to go we haven't I mean I
feel like we might even step our toes
into Earth in the next season possibly
yeah if that's where Lilith is uh and
maybe that's what we determined that
Redemption doesn't get you to heaven
gets you back on Earth or something well
for a show about Redemption what I
really liked about what this finale did
was like it brought her back around to
Family Matters and uh that you know for
not forgiving others but self
forgiveness as well like a lot of like
Heavenly themes but applied in the
status of hell I thought was was really
great you know and I don't know how
people will feel about the finale I like
the finale I did too but it didn't go
out with the bang that I thought it
might which was like telling us what the
Alistar situation
was uh yeah they left the little they
left a little more seeds dangling and I
I
still it it went the direction that you
expect like a big blowout Adam di you're
surprised Adam dies it seemed like he
was pretty obvious he was going to die I
wasn't surprised that he died as in when
I asked you like do you think he's going
to die I also thought he was going to
die I'm just saying that if you had told
me if you told me a few episodes like do
you think he's going to die this season
I would said probably not because he
seems like such a big villain MH that I
thought they might move forward with but
it is cool he's the big bad of season
one
yeah Where's God in all
this Where's God in all this Greg well
that doesn't matter we're talking about
fiction where have you heard about
simulation Theory you don't know that
this isn't fiction I I would I think
this is a terrible simulation then yeah
terrible that's God's fault I need to
sign up for a bigger simulation need a
new deal next simulation uh yeah the
because they don't even talk about God
yeah it's that's something that even the
this it's funny I love the show
Supernatural I know you do and they do
there's they avoid they they get like
every religion involved and they mainly
Thrive off Christianity and they have
another thing like angels are bad too as
well like it's a whole conversation it
took a while for them to really talk
about God and bring you know that
equation as well they'll always have
like crucifixes and stuff but they never
talk about Jesus and I I think there's
like certain subjects that they kind of
stray away from but I think you got to
bring God into the equation like you
have to well we're in heaven yeah
exactly so you have to bring the create
the the supposed creator of all uh into
it what about the devil that Lucifer is
but like we haven't seen him as the
devil at all uh this is their
interpretation of what the devil he's
still the devil you know but it's just
the interpretation of it of Lucifer
himself but I I like Lucifer stepping in
I thought the action was really cool I'm
trying to figure out what that punches
that was missing for me it doesn't
really even come out of reveals there
was just something there that it's
better than a Marvel finale but it's
kind of like a Marvel finale you know I
still really again I think it knows it's
getting its season two and sometimes
when we're watching so many movies at
the end you feel more fulfilled because
you're like oh okay that's what that
story was but oft times as you know I'm
a TV Junkie at the end of a season one
you're like what
that's it what do I you know what do I
do from here
yeah well it's seems that Charlie is
going to become a beast a beast a strong
leader and that's what I mean like we
were I kept saying that I think that
we're going to see her get more
Unleashed throughout the SE series and
then this one really teased that a lot
she even had the whole tail and
everything and she was like hulking out
and and devil form i l it so hot stuff
it's hot there God it's me Greg and
Roxy what where did that come from
because uh we're talking about hopeful
for season two and things that are H did
you ever read are you there God it's me
Margaret yeah I'm the guy who would read
or did you see the movie no do you know
the movie I know that's the oh my God
what it's one of the biggest movies from
last year Rachel McAdams is in it um
it's called are you there God it's me
Margaret it's made after the book
whatever you're saying Where's God I was
still on it it was one of the biggest
movies of last year it was big movie
last year yeah big box office movie
really I don't mean one of the biggest
is in like a tent pole that was but yeah
yeah was theater theatrical release cool
it was it's really good um it was um
Kelly Fremont Craig her follow up to
edge of 17 oh cool and it's based on
this book that was like it's a book
about coming of age getting your period
it's like a book that most my friends
most PE girls I know my age read it
anyway are you there God it's me Greg
and Roxy I'm glad hear we want to see
you on hasbin Hotel season two
yeah all right well great WAP up song I
we feel like it was pretty
straightforward it was an action
episode but defeated heaven and I mean
yeah they and and I think I really think
what I'm hoping for season two was one
of the best parts that I think about
this show that that I felt like kept
ramping up and I do feel like they kind
of dialed it back in these last couple
episodes those last couple became very
straightforward and I liked the
complexity and M and multi- leress of
everything they were doing prior like
even when she goes to heaven there is
such a conversation there's a debate
about everything yeah they were able to
have more fun in those episodes because
they didn't have to accomplish as much
we were on kind of like side missions
and I think a de like you can really
open up a conversation here of you know
the The Duality of opinions in heaven of
what they should do about hell like
there can be a divide in heaven and I
hope they go into that terrain too I I
think like as much as Everything feels
celebratory there's also a lot of
complications that can erupt from
something like this you know yeah and
and I hope that they they go there
because the last two have been very
straightforward and they kind of played
out in a way that was cathartic at the
same time uh nothing was as the most
unexpected thing was revenges go but
that was really unexpected expected
that's bigger than we think and I think
that speaks to the central theme of this
show which is my takeaway of this entire
season and of this show which is who
gets to
decide what's good what's bad and and
what are like when we had that episode
with the three episode with the three
qualifications right who picks those and
who's to say really and uh on your best
day would you go to heaven and on your
worst day would you go to hell I bet
every person probably on their best and
worst day would be one of those two no
matter where you are in that Spectrum so
I think that the serpenta stuff really
made a difference because it leaves me
to believe that this show knows that
that's its main theme yeah well before
we go is your Friday really
busy yeah you're going to have a lot of
comments to respond
to I can't wait I hope we have hours of
free time I only respond to comments
that say my name because I'm vain and um
comments that are nice because I can't
be down in the mud with the
Trolls but those can you can waste the
most time there I know you can go down a
big vacuum and I want to live in heaven
it is a hell I've done it I've done it
many times are you there
God it many times you should react to
that movie it was so good okay I
appreciate the
recommendation anyway ladies and
gentlemen hasb been Hotel was the finale
satisfying for you leave your thoughts
down below ask Roxy questions season 1
has
been a a great season a a hotel listen
I'm going to grab some food and work on
videos to get these to these guys but
thank you Roxy for joining me on this
journey thank you for having this be the
first show we cover together many more
to come yes many one more to come
and and then uh we're going to old
school this time to warm up the Brain
before we film a movie reaction so thank
you to all who have joined for this tier
I want to shout all you guys out
individually one at a time we'll do more
than just say your name we're going get
some serious bars starting with Matthew
arms delivering all the charm arms Jack
Forest uh in a Ford
tus nice and namari constantly eating
all that calamari Mike Joyce in a
rollsroyce everyone gets a car in my
version hope you
commit locked now
maybe Ryan Smith the ultimate dark side
of the Sith Kevin Meek in the front
seat Adrian Tim's addicted to playing
the The Sims nav deep
sidu uh you can borrow my Subaru real
Naga rh's real Heather gear put it in
Heather GE Heather first gear that's the
appropriate
version Ian Simon always be rhyming
Jacob Neptune drives the
Saturn Kayla the king always rocking
that sexy bling looks like I'm riding
with Olivier ham
got it did it ring ring I'm getting a
phone call from Allan Ling Kier if I
removed some of the letters from your
name it would be Kia
sento ju Longoria I aim to bore you I'm
going to drive right off a cliff
Rodriguez Ian wreck constantly listening
to back goat Nation could you tow me to
the gas station Lorenzo back
ride me faster differently saying going
to hydro plane in the rain that's still
a car thing Marco tun still always out
for the ultimate kill simply faded
tinted windows you got to get a new set
of tinted windows on your car my friend
SJ 94 always cutting right to the core
Justin Aston Martin the perfect one
about phone be calling calling and he's
on the phone balling Philip J Smith
Jr Mitsubishi used to make cars remember
that just that you just made me think of
that so that's that's for you Jen Smith
hips have a nice
withy Melanie LeBlanc Melanie Le
Bronco that's not bad that feel like you
would drive a Bronco too and and also
now that I'm think thinking about it
Kevin Meek could have been Kevin jeep
that would have been better but anyway
Kier could have been Toyota Kiera could
have been Toyota that might have been a
good rhyme there's so many options NE
tune in next month when I uh bring a
whole boatload more other car uh
references to fits your names we didn't
do Tesla there was nobody got to be a
Tesla or a Porsche or a a
Lamborghini and then you just had like a
grab bag of fun and fanciful had the
hard job yeah yes you did you carried
this and I commend you for it thanks
guys for carrying
[Music]
us